mais c'est de la merde
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Pierre Coffe
Jean-Pierre
Jean-Pierre bonsoir vous êtes ici ce
soir pour la sortie d'un DVD que tout le
monde attendait un best of de vos plus
beaux c'est de la merde
avec le célèbre c'est de la merde le
jambon sous vide c'est de la merde le
poisson pané c'est de la merde Michel
Drucker
non mais c'est vrai qu'il est bourré de
colorants et de conservateur pour
paraître plus jeune Michel
[Rires]
de la merde en mémoire du bon vieux
temps mais c'est de la merde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Jean-Pierre Coffe évidemment personne ne
fera jamais mieux que vous donc votre
dernier livre le plaisir à petit prix
bien manger en famille pour moins de 9
euros par jour chez plomb étant tête des
ventes 300 000 exemplaires bravo
bravo bravo parce que d'habitude votre
étiage vous c'est autour de 100 000 et
là vous êtes à trois fois votre vente
habituelle quoi ce qui veut dire c'est
vraiment la crise quoi si je devais vous
dire quelque chose je dirais que ça ne
me rend pas heureux parce que écrire un
bouquin sur la crise ça veut dire que
les gens sont dans la merde des gens qui
achètent des bouquins à 9 euros pour
voir comment ils peuvent manger à 8 je
trouve pas que ça soit réjouissant
d'abord parce que ça fait pas beaucoup
de droits d'auteur quand même c'est une
base en 2002 c'était comment bien manger
pour 15 euros et aujourd'hui c'est 9
euros mais alors à 9 euros qu'est-ce
qu'on mange à ce prix-là le bouquin quoi
non parce qu'après on a plus de recettes
alors votre recette effectivement c'est
d'abord de supprimer le superflu alors
là ça va un peu loin parce que dans
votre bouquin il est jamais question de
steak par exemple ça n'empêche pas de
manger du bœuf pour autant le bas
morceau c'est c'est toujours du bœuf ou
c'est toujours de l'agneau c'est
toujours du veau donc c'est là où il
faut aller alors d'abord supprimer le
superflu donc ensuite manger des fruits
des légumes de saison évidemment on peut
les manger on conserve ou surgelés ça
n'est pas interdit plutôt en conserve
qu'en surgelé parce que c'est moins cher
quel gourou ce coffre oui maître quel
gourou
faut aussi éviter les produits
manufacturés qu'on peut faire soi-même
alors les carottes râpées alors les
carottes râpées c'est incroyable parce
que si on achète des carottes râpées
avec une vinaigrette industrielle ça
coûte une merde ça c'est de la merde
et celles qu'on rappe chez soi à la
maison les bonnes petites carottes de la
maison avec un filet d'huile d'olive
vous faites
633% d'économies par rapport à ce que
vous allez acheter chez un charcutier
dont c'est pas le métier qui va
l'acheter industriel dont c'est pas le
métier et qui va rajouter une
vinaigrette dont c'est pas le métier non
plus donc finalement faites vous-même
alors ça ça va encore mais vous
recommander également le pain rassis
vous auriez connu la guerre on se
régalait d'une soupe aux pins et
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de mieux vous qui
avez des enfants faites leurs dons un un
pain perdu c'est mieux qu'une barre au
chocolat pourri avec de la saloperie
dedans c'est de la merde et disons-le
vous vous recommandez aussi de de
réutiliser les épluchures de pommes de
terre quand on fait des frites vous la
mettez dans une friteuse mais c'est une
frite exquise parce que n'oubliez pas
que tout est vitamines sont dans les
fluchures d'accord
et alors le pire de tous c'est garder le
départ que je m'en fous de le départ
mais vous en faites une soupe vous
faites ce que vous voulez vous faites
cuire vos légumes là-dedans la vitamine
et les dents les oligo-éléments sont là
donc vous en servez vu la gravité de la
crise évidemment vous préparez la suite
bien manger pour moins de 3 euros par
jour vous expliquer comment faire des
spaghettis avec des glacés de chaussures
comment cuisiner des cocottes Dora et
ramasser des chats morts au bord des
routes alors évidemment
à 3 euros par jour mais qu'est-ce que
vous voulez bouffer alors Jean-Pierre la
campagne qui recommande 5 fruits cinq
légumes par jour ça sort d'où parce que
pour une famille de 4 c'est comme 131
euros par mois ça fait 13% du SMIC donc
les gens comment ils font c'est
nécessaire ouais le plan de la santé
mais c'est irréfléchit sur le plan de la
communication et sur le plan de la
consommation Jean-Pierre quand on lit
votre livre on pense effectivement à des
recettes de temps de guerre et quand on
s'intéresse à votre vie on comprend d'où
ça vient vous laisser en 1938 à
Lunéville votre père était coiffeur vous
l'avez jamais connu parce qu'il a été
mobilisé en 1937 tué en 1940 vous vous
aviez à l'époque deux ans et demi vous
êtes devenu pupille de la nation et
pendant la débats que avec votre mère
vous fuyez la Lorraine pour vous
réfugier près de Saumur dans une
champignonnière au bord de la Loire et
là la nuit c'est le cauchemar quoi et
des rats qui passent entre vos jambes
oui mais on a plus peur de rien quand un
truc comme ça vous arrive alors quand
votre mère rentre à Lunéville pour
reprendre le salon de coiffure familial
là c'est la zone si vous avez pas
d'argent vous êtes obligé de cueillir
des pissenlits sur le terrain de
football pour avoir un semblant de
salade quoi il y avait rien à acheter
donc moi je me souviens des coin de
l'art elle faisait trois plats de
patates d'accord la première fois
c'était très très bon la deuxième fois
ça fait encore un petit goût de fumée la
troisième fois on savait ce que c'était
des pommes de terre c'est tellement dur
que vous faisiez du savon avec des
marrons que vous alliez chercher dans la
forêt ça marche le marron mais oui parce
qu'on est on les épluche et on les
frottait sur une sorte de pierre ponce
on récupérerait la purée qui était là et
on avait séché au four et après on s'en
servait pour cela pour se laver pour la
ville surtout heureusement grâce à la
Croix Rouge vous partez en Suisse en
tant que pupille de la nation où là vous
découvrez campagne cet amour de la
campagne que vous avez vient de votre
grand-père qui était maraîcher mais
aussi du temps que vous avez passé en
Suisse c'est là où j'ai appris l'amour
moi avec qui et avec des bêtes
la vie c'est mieux de démagasines aussi
internet quand vous voyez le cheval qui
est en train de monter la jument c'est
d'une beauté inouïe parce que vous savez
ça ce que ça fait ça m'a appris
d'attendre à dire quand le coït était
terminé la tête de l'étalon se penche
tout à coup reposer sur l'encolure de la
jument c'est d'une beauté
une émotion alors de retour en France
votre mère habite à Paris et là vous
découvrez l'Opéra Comique alors il y a
une chanson que vous m'avez apprise il y
a quelques années
20 chemin
ne va trottine va petit
âne va dessus de la récompense
vous inscrivez aux Cours Simon vous
voulez faire du théâtre à l'époque vous
donner des répliques à Pierre mondire à
Sami frais et alors incroyable et pour
payer vos cours de théâtre vous êtes
obligé de faire du repassage la nuit je
vous repasser de 4 heures à 7h du matin
c'était un travail de chien
vous avez des petits rôles vous faites
des tournées en province etc jusqu'au
service militaire et à 18 ans alors là
vous pesez 120 kilos c'est quoi vous
vouliez faire Guy Carlier comme métier
dans la vie quoi non non surtout pas
vous avez perdu comment la différence je
suis allé voir une imbécile
et on m'a refilé ils ont fait Tamines
qui est la dernière des conneries qu'il
faut faire bien entendu on mange pas
c'est vrai on maigrit c'est vrai quel
dégât donc c'est là où je suis devenu
chauve voilà c'est voilà ce que ça fait
mais voilà donc après l'armée vous vous
mariez vous passez une petite annonce
dans le Figaro je ne sais rien faire
mais j'ai plein de bonnes volonté et
vous allez quand même 11 réponses et
vous trouvez un job chez job oui
incroyable
j'ai amélioré la qualité du papier on
utilise toujours des du papier jaune
d'ailleurs non mais ça se passe très
bien au bout de 7 ans vous êtes
directeur commercial et là vous avez un
accident passer deux ans dans un lit
quand même oui ça c'est pas le moment le
plus rigolo alors ensuite vous faites
une agence de relation presse relation
publique ensuite vous montez un
restaurant tout Paris défile dans ce
restaurant jusqu'au jour où des bars
Pierre Lescure qui vous fait évidemment
des propositions sur sur Canal+ où vous
travaillez avec Michel Denisot c'est
surtout deniso qui a eu l'idée je tiens
à rectifier
l'escu à accepter mais c'est Michel
Denisot à qui je dois de faire de la
télé bravo Michel merci Michel
alors vous avez travaillé aussi avec de
la rue à qui vous avez appris l'amour
des bons produits parce que grâce à vous
maintenant quand il frappe quelqu'un
dans un avion c'est pas avec un saumon
d'élevage ça avec un saumon sauvage
ça n'est ni un sujet ni une personne qui
m'intéresse à ce point-là
c'est mieux pas traîner dans les
cuvettes de garde
[Applaudissements]
je pense que nous en resterons là
aujourd'hui donc vous êtes chez Michel
Drucker hein ça se passe bien vivement
dimanche c'est toujours Sarkozy qui
produit l'émission oui toujours il vient
avec sa femme
bon en tout cas vous avez 71 ans
dis-donc bravo
[Applaudissements]
et apparemment
il y a pas de date limite de
consommation vous êtes toujours là très
en forme
date limite approche mais pour le moment
il est toujours pas sûr de vous enterrer
mais toujours notre regardons-nous et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de tube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu